guten tag ich weiß nicht ob sie schon
davon gehört haben aber die welt gibt es
nicht einhörner existieren gehirn können
nicht denken genauso wenig wie computer
ach ja und die weitverbreitete rede von
einem post faktischen zeitalter in
wahrheit nichts als verblasen der unsinn
das sind nur einige der kernsätze einer
radikal neuen philosophie die unsere
kultur von ihren tiefsten ja
todbringenden irrtümern heilen will ihr
schöpfer sitzt mir direkt gegenüber
erste aufregung denker unserer zeit der
bonner philosoph markus gabriel herr
gabriel schön sind sie da
danke für die einladung herr gabriel ihr
eigene zeit von ihrem größten irrtümern
zu heilen auf das man gemeinsam besser
handeln kann
das ist doch eine weise ihre mission die
vision der philosophie selbst zu
beschreiben oder in der tat so verstehe
ich tatsächlich die philosophie als eine
intervention in den zeitgeist um dort
eben nach teils verborgenen und teils
auch ganz offenkundigen fehlschlüssen
und eben auch für uns als menschen
gefährlichen irrtümern zu suchen um sie
dann mit den methoden der philosophie zu
korrigieren und wenn man so will auch zu
heilen dann intervenieren sie doch mal
was sind denn die großen drei irrtümer
die unsere zeit plagen derzeit ja ich
würde sagen wenn ich drei benennen
müsste wäre das erstens der gedanke dass
die gesamte wirklichkeit ja physikalisch
messbar und naturwissenschaftlich
beschreibbar ist so dass es in
wirklichkeit nichts gibt was nicht
naturwissenschaftlich erforscht ist
physikalisch muss etwa physik als erster
oder zweiter irrtum das denken geist
bewusstsein unsere inneren geistigen
mentalen zustände nichts anderes sind
als agent also ausstrahlende phänomene
des gehirns neu eurozentrismus es weiter
und der dritte irrtum ist der gedanke
dass es keine objektiv fest stehenden
werte maßstäbe ethischer natur gibt das
also was wir tun oder unterlassen sollen
aus moralischen gründen lediglich eine
abitur setzung einer kultur oder des
menschlichen geistes ist das nenne ich
moralischen nihilismus das ist der
dritte also physikalisch muss neuronal
ismus nihilismus als die plagegeister
unserer zeit würden sie denn sagen
sie sind für das abendland typisch oder
sind die global ausgebreitet
mittlerweile also ich glaube die sind
tatsächlich global ausgebreitet auch
wenn man in den verschiedenen
philosophischen traditionen ja west und
ost nord und süd schaut wird man fast
überall dort wo die philosophie in der
vergangenheit oder gegenwart geblüht hat
varianten dieses gedanken finden es auch
in der altindischen philosophie gab es
materialistischer ansätze also
bestreitung des freien willens
bestreitung der existenz von denken oder
objektiven werten das findet man
tatsächlich in allen philosophischen
traditionen soweit sie dokumentiert sind
also die irrtümer sind alt die sind aber
heute in verschärfter form sozusagen
unser weltbild eingelassen in ein
globales irrtums fällt wenn man so will
krisenzeiten sind ja oft zeiten in denen
ihre firma besonders sichtbar werden und
das jahr 2020 war sich eine erfahrung
als pandemie erfahrung die uns besonders
zu denken gegeben hat es betrifft das
verhältnis von globalisierung und uns
von wissenschaft und demokratie von
prognose und fakt zwischen modell und
leugnung würden sie denn sagen dass das
jahr 2020 eines ist in denen diese
irrtümer besonders schädlich
hervorgetreten sind ja in der tat ist ja
vieles von dem was wir jetzt angesichts
der viralen pandemie und der mit dieser
natürlich eng verwobenen krisen nicht
stichwort krise der liberalen demokratie
und soziale netzwerke er in gruppiert
sich um donald trump herum aber
natürlich gibt es das in asien auch mit
tim bin sogar noch viel schlimmer oder
in russland mit putin das heißt diese
ganzen krisen phänomene die verstärken
in der tat ja diese drei irrtümer und
die werden auch von denen getrieben
getragen also nehmen wir bloß ja in
unseren tagen etwa das gesamte phänomen
der korona leugnung her dass ja daran
besteht dass wir angesichts
wissenschaftlicher expertise irritiert
sind und zwar alle
ja da sind einerseits sozusagen die
physikalischen die sagen die korona
pandemie ist nichts anderes als ein
medizinisches phänomen auch das ist
falsch und dann am anderen extrem findet
man menschen die glauben die gesamte
pandemie sei nur ein politisches oder
soziales phänomen aber es hat ja auch
damit zu tun dass man den verursacher
dieser pandemie diesen virus so ganz
schwer zu fassen kriegt etwas fast
fantastisches irgendwo lauert da aber so
richtig kriegen wir ihn wohl nicht am
schlafittchen oder
viren haben eben die interessante und
unangenehme eigenschaft ja wie das für
mikroben üblich ist dass sie unterhalb
weit unterhalb der skala der
sichtbarkeit für uns existieren ja ich
frage oft meine virologischen kollegen
welche farbe hat denn das corona virus
und die richtige antwort darauf scheint
zu sein keine ist zu klein das heißt im
grunde genommen sind wir hier sogar in
einer welt unterhalb der farben ja wir
sind also unterhalb des uns als menschen
sichtbaren spektrums der wirklichkeit
und von dort kommt eine letztlich nicht
direkt beobachtbare sondern nur durch
tests erlebbare gefahr
und das ist natürlich eine unheimliche
erfahrung für uns menschen denn es zeigt
uns dass wir nicht herren sind im
eigenen oder frauen im eigenen haus wir
haben nicht die kontrolle über das was
geschieht eine erfahrung dieser pandemie
ist ja auch dass der tod mitten zurück
in unser leben gekehrt ist und eine
philosophie die diesen tod oder diese
todesangst als ein ausgangspunkt war der
existentialismus sie nennen ihre eigene
philosophie neo existenzialismus wie
kommt es dazu ja unter neo
existenzialismus das epizentrum im
grunde genommen allem einer
philosophischen überlegungen verstehe
ich den gedanken dass menschen ein leben
im licht einer vorstellung von sich
führen das heißt wir haben ja alle ein
bild davon wie wir in die weitere
wirklichkeit passen was menschliche
tiere von nicht-menschlichen tieren
unterscheidet was alle tiere von der
nicht belebten natur unterscheidet und
wie wir eben ins universum als ganzes
passen ja wir haben also wie man so sagt
welt und menschenbilder und wesen dieser
welt und menschenbilder haben haben eine
spezifische art der freiheit denn was
wir tun und wer wir sind hängt unter
anderem davon ab wofür wir uns halten
das ist die existenzialistische grund
überzeugt habe ich das mal kurz zu
formulieren die menschen können sich nur
verstehen und müssen sich nur verstehen
in dem sich ein bild von der welt und
von sich selbst machen und je nachdem
welches bild sie haben werden sie so
oder so handeln genau
ganz konkret ja man stelle sich vor ein
philosoph etwa wie der philosoph daniel
dennett oder andere richard dawkins
theoretiker die glauben dass menschen so
eine art hochgerüstete killer affen sind
ja die vollständig evolutionär erklären
und beschreibbar sind werden ja sich im
alltag ganz anders verhalten als etwa
jemand sagen der papst franziskus der
glaubt er habe eine unsterbliche seele
ja also wenn man glaubt dass wir in
diesem leben getestet werden von einem
transzendenten gott oder von vielen
göttern wenn man polizistin ist ja dann
hat das natürlich konsequenzen anbetet
oder betet nicht fastet oder fast nicht
man nähert sich sexuell menschen völlig
anders an je nachdem welches bild man da
von hardware oder was man ist jetzt
verstehe ich auch ihren einsatz besser
wenn man falsche bilder kann man nicht
richtig handeln die philosophie ist die
therapie von den falschen bildern das
könnte man darüber sagen es gibt
menschen wenn man die sparkassen welt
nur habe ich nicht brauche ich keins
kann ich mir nicht leisten sind das den
menschen die wahrheit sagen oder sich
über sich selbst täuschen
ich glaube die täuschen sich tatsächlich
auch schon über sich selbst denn jeder
mensch hat eine implizit oder explizit
antwort häufig überliefert man hat zu
hause gehört ja also irgendeine antwort
darauf was es bedeutet ein mensch zu
sein
er hat das ist die berühmte frage nach
dem sinn des lebens jeder jede von uns
gibt dem sinn gibt dem leben einen sinn
und darin besteht eben unsere geistige
freiheit also ein mensch zu sein heißt
genau das ja damit beschäftigt zu sein
die frage zu beantworten was es heißt
jemand zu sein man könnte auch sagen wir
es können sind wesen die nicht anders
können als sich etwas vorzumachen wir
leben in bildern von dieser welt in
vorstellungen infektion wir sind
fiktional gewesen richtig das nenne ich
genau auf fiktionen möchte aber
hinzufügen und das ist ein
entscheidender variante im neo
existenzialismus das unterscheidet
meinen philosophischen ansatz etwa von
demjenigen jean paul sartres oder martin
heideggers ja um andere berühmte
existenziell ist ist ja auch gesagt
haben wir haben nicht die freiheit keine
freiheit zu haben wir haben nicht die
freiheit kein selbstbild sahen wir haben
immer schon eins wir müssen es eine
explizit machen richtig die dachten aber
dass es in einem bestimmten sinne keine
wahrheit über uns gibt sondern die
dachten eben wie gesagt nicht mal macht
sich immer etwas vor und es gibt kein
unabhängiges kriterium
er hat dass uns etwas darüber lehrt wer
wir sind das glaube ich nicht ich glaube
es gibt eben objektiv richtige antworten
zum beispiel habe ich entweder ein
unsterbliche seele oder
ich habe keine glaube ich jetzt ein und
zu haben habe aber keines dass eine
spezifische form der täuschung
die wäre anders wenn es eben eine gibt
oder nicht das hängt also von den
tatsachen ab und der neo
existenzialismus ist eng verwoben mit
meinem allgemeinen ansatz dem neuen
realismus das heißt er basiert auf der
anerkennung einer von uns hat partiell
unabhängigen wirklichkeit da kommen wir
gleich dazu aber erst mal geht es auch
um das schein und in sein
ich bin jemand der immer sagt das erste
buch der erste satz eines buches der es
ganz wichtig bei ihnen in ihrem neuen
buch fiktionen lautet der erste satz der
schein ist sein dass ja geradezu eine
umkehrung der gesamten abendländischen
philosophie die sagen würde sein und
schein sind zwei ganz verschiedene dinge
sie sagen der schein ist sein was meinen
sie damit
deswegen habe ich auch es freut mich
wenn jemand so liest ich bin auch jemand
für den der erste satz und auch das
letzte wort eines buches eine besondere
bedeutung haben sollten
der fanfarenstoß mit dem ich deswegen
das buch auch so beginne ist in der tat
ein abgesang auf die tradition der
philosophie 2500 jahre sind wir ehrlich
genau im wesentlichen sei erwachsen zeit
hat man das andersrum gesehen
und hier ist der gedanke dass eben keine
flucht aus der wirklichkeit möglich ist
ja also es ist nicht möglich dass der
schein sozusagen nicht zur wirklichkeit
gehört sondern der schein ist eben genau
so wirklich ja wie scheint freies also
wenn ich zum beispiel die falsche
meinung habe gerade in bern zu sein
obwohl ich eben in zürich bin dann ist
dieser schein ja selber etwas wirklich
ist machen wir mal ein beispiel die
probe aufs exempel
es gibt optische täuschungen wie dieser
hier beispielsweise der schein sagt
diese linien sind nicht gleich lang
die wahrheit ist diese linien sind
gleich lang ist eine optische täuschung
selbst wenn wir wissen dass sie gleich
lang sind sehen wir sie als verschieden
lang und sie sagen jetzt der schein ist
ein sein
das heißt der schein dass sie
verschieden lang sind ist auch eine form
von wirklichkeit genau diese
wirklichkeit kann man ja eben messen wir
hätten ja gar nicht feststellen können
zb anhand psychologische analysen ja
dass menschen zb opfer dieser
sinnestäuschung sind der müller li
illusion ja und alle wahrnehmungen hat
ein solches element der illusion wenn
ich mich jetzt von ihnen weg bewegen
könnte ich ja den eindruck erhalten dass
sie kleiner werden durch die distanz ja
das co
gierig aber dass das system mensch
korrigiert da ist weil wir natürlich
wissen dass berge in der ferne nicht
kleiner werden nur weil wir auf abstand
von ihnen sind und nun könnte man sagen
wir menschen haben die fähigkeit den
schein als scheint zu entlarven
dadurch wird aber für uns erst mal nicht
weniger wirklich genau der schein
verschwindet ja nicht also egal was ich
über die müller li religion weiß sie
geht nicht weg und egal was ich über
ihre faktische größe weiß scheint sie
scheinen immer noch kleiner zu werden
wenn ich mich von ihnen weg bewegen das
heißt der scheinen gehört zur textur
unseres geistigen lebens wir können den
nur korrigieren
ja also meine these ist nicht bestecken
immer im schein fest und kommen nicht
aus ihm heraus sondern wir können den
schein korrigieren und das ist eben auch
unsere aufgabe als erkennende lebewesen
die wissens ansprüche hin weltbilder
sagen sie sind da wir können kein nicht
keine haben es gibt es so kleine private
weltbilder und es gibt große
ausgearbeitete die nennen wir dann
philosophien wenn man ihre bücher der
letzten zehn jahre liest hat man das
gefühl die philosophie für die letzten
2500 jahre war nicht ein sie war der
schädlichste faktor in unserer kultur
weil die welt bilder die sie nahe liegt
falsch sind in der tat die philosophie
war nicht so wie wir jetzt von pandemie
treibern sprechen war die philosophie
auch ein irrtums treiber über mehrere
tausend jahre weil sie eben auf dem
gedanken aufgebaut hat der so genannten
achsen zeit wie das karl jaspers genannt
hat das heißt auf den gedanken dass es
ein allumfassendes ganzes gibt dessen
teil wir sind heute sprechen wir vom
universum der wirklichen land der welt
dem seien ja es gibt viele titel oder
auch natur das ist der gedanke dass da
etwas riesengroßes ist und wir sind
immer ein kleiner teil
und dieses riesengroße müssten wir doch
irgendwie erforschen ja die erforschung
des allergrößten ganzen heißt
traditionell metaphysik und heute
glauben eben viele menschen dass die
metaphysik in physik überführt wurde dh
dass die physikalische kosmologie die
uns etwas über den urknall und die
entwicklung der raumzeit brauchen keine
metaphysik mehr das machen jetzt die
physiker vor gericht ich aber das ist
dieselbe art von illusion das heißt
diese auffassung der physik ist eben
selber eine metaphysik das heißt eine
philosophische interpretation etwa
physikalischer gleichungen nichts daran
ist selbstverständlich und ich versuche
auch die wissenschaften von der
metaphysik zu befreien
bevor wir das mal ganz konkret machen
meine frage sie sind jetzt ein junger
fans so sie waren der jüngste professor
und deutschland sie haben mittlerweile
zwei große forschungszentren in bonn
sie greifen das darf man sagen und
gelten als eine art wunderkind der
philosophie jetzt treten sie auch mit
einem anspruch der nicht bescheiden ist
und den sie auch nicht beschreiben
nennen was die letzten 2500 jahre lief
ist falsch und ich markus gabriel
ich erkläre ich das jetzt wie reagieren
denn ihre kollegen und kolleginnen auf
diesen anspruch naja also im besten fall
durch gegenargumente dh durch
auseinandersetzung mit den thesen und
den gründen die ich für meine thesen
formuliere also wissenschaftlich im
schlimmsten fall durch irgendetwas was
man wiederum pathologische einstufen
muss das interessiert mich aber als
philosophen natürlich nicht als menschen
schon aber nicht als philosophen als
philosoph interessiere mich einwände die
ich erhalte
und ich behaupte ja erstens dass gewisse
thesen richtig sind für die ich
argumentiere und zweitens dass die
kombination der thesen völlig neu ist
also dass diese kombination seit 2500
jahren nicht vorgelegen hat beides sind
falsifiziert bahre behauptung stellen
das in den raum und wenn ihm jemand mit
einem besseren argument kommt dann
werden wir das auch anerkennen dann
revidiere ich dass deswegen setze ich
mich in meinen schriften immer
auseinander mit den besten rational
ssten gegen einwenden die ich auf
vortragsreisen oder in philosophischen
einzelgesprächen erhalten habe nur so
kommt man in der philosophie voran
na klar so würden es auch erwarten dann
fangen wir mal mit einer art
grundeinstellung unseres welt zugangs an
da gibt es eine erzählung die fast alle
teil die lautet so da draußen gibt es
eine wahrnehmungs unabhängige
wirklichkeit und in dieser wirklichkeit
gibt es denkendes objekte die die
aufgabe haben diese wirklichkeit zu
erkennen
das ist eine art grundsätzen des
abendlandes und sie sagen schon schon da
läuft es falsch was stimmt an dieser
idee nicht draußen gibt es tische bäume
hunde und es gibt menschen die versuchen
zu erkennen wie die wirklichkeit da
draußen beschaffen ist ja also das erste
problem bei dieser räumlichen metapher
ist dass wir ja auch da draußen sind ja
also erstens befinde ich mich ja
zwischen den unten bäumen katzen und
matratzen als teil des mobiliars dieser
wirklichkeit wir sind schon mittendrin
immer ganz genau wir müssen nicht erst
einen zugang finden zur wirklichkeit
sondern wir sind in der wirklichkeit
selbst und der zugang zur wirklichkeit
ist ja selbst entweder etwas wirkliches
oder nichts wirkliches ist ja nichts
wirklich es kann nicht gelingen ist der
selber etwas wirkliches haben wir schon
alles geleistet was wir uns irgendwie
hart erarbeiten wollten durch
philosophische meditationen oder
erkenntnistheoretische übungen also
haben wir als objekte gar keine aufgabe
zur welt zu kommen weil wir immer schon
bei der welt sind wir sind mittendrin im
wirklichen das wirkliche bilder zwar
keine welt also keinen allumfassenden
strukturierten zusammenhang aber das
wirklich ist genau das jenige von dem
wir zu dem er nicht auf distanz gehen
können also jeder fluchtversuch
scheitert am wirklichen dadurch dass die
flucht selber schon zum wirklichen
gehört der einzige ausweg ist der tod
und nicht einmal das
und könnte man nicht sagen träume zum
beispiel wenn wir schlafen das heißt
auch genau so wirklich wie hunde katzen
und 19 absolut ja weil die mentale
zustände die ich habe während ich träume
gehören jahr zur wirklichkeit deswegen
kann man unter anderem von außen durch
geeignete psycho metrische verfahren
bildgebende verfahren oder ähnliches
feststellen ob ich träume oder nicht
träume daran sieht man auch meinen
träumen ist etwas wirkliches und auch
die gegenstand stände meines träumen
sind etwas wirkliches sind raum
gestalten die unterscheiden sich von
ihnen in vielerlei hinsichten aber
dennoch sind sie etwas wirkliches jetzt
verstehe ich schon besser was sie sagen
der schein und das sein sind eigentlich
1 weil träume sind teil der wirklichkeit
als reale ereignisse ganz genau so jetzt
gibt es in diesem weltbild da draußen
gibt es eine wirklichkeit noch einen
spezifischen zugang der würde sagen was
es da draußen wirklich gibt das sagt uns
nicht die theologie das hat uns die
physik die physik oder die
naturwissenschaften sagen uns was es da
draußen wirklich gibt und nur das was
die physik für wirklich hält ist auch
wirklich nach ihrer ansicht falsch
richtig völlig falsch bei der satz
selbst ja nicht zum beispiel durch die
physik erhoben wird das heißt die physik
kann nicht selber etwa den satz sinnvoll
äußern oder wissenschaftlich begründen
dass nur das was die physik erkennen
kann wirklich ist das ist ja selber
schon mal kein physikalischer satz das
unterminiert erstens schon mal den
anspruch und zeigt dass wir es hier mit
metaphysik und eben nicht mit physik zu
tun haben zweitens ist es viel zu leicht
zu widerlegen ja also es gibt viele
gegenstände kobolde die zahl zwei
gerechtigkeit den status der
bundeskanzlerin bundeskanzlerin zu sein
die gegenstände und wahrheit tatsachen
sind offensichtlich nicht gegenstand der
physik weil sie die gar nicht adäquat
beschreiben könnten mit ihren
physikalischen formeln genau es gibt
keine physik der bundestagswahl 20 21
jetzt könnte man sagen dass ein bisschen
die gefährliche rede für den philosophen
weil in einer zeit in der die
wissenschaft unter druck ist kommt jetzt
ein neuer philosoph und sagt die haben
ansprüche die sind völlig falsch die
denken sie sagen uns was wirklich ist
das können sie gar nicht sehen sie da
eine spannung zwischen einerseits den
beschneiden von wissens ansprüchen der
wissenschaft und andererseits die
autorität der wissenschaftlich zu
gefährden ja also ich sage gar nicht das
naturwissenschaftliche einzel
erkenntnisse setzte theorien oder
modelle falsch sind
im gegenteil ich sage nur die
beschreiben nicht die wirklichkeit als
ganzes oder auch nicht die fundamentale
der wirklichkeit wenn ich wissen will
welche biochemischen eigenschaften das
neuartige coronaviren hat dann muss ich
die virologen fragen niemanden sonst
bitte nicht mich da müssen sie meine
kollegen fragen ja das ist also völlig
klar die haben da noch recht aber die
biologinnen und biologen könnten
wiederum nichts vernünftiges darüber
aussagen welche sozialen folgekosten zb
pandemie bekämpfung haben da müssen sie
jetzt soziologin fragen oder experten
aus anderen gebieten ja daran sieht man
das sofort also einerseits die autorität
der wissenschaft lokal stärken
andererseits die über griffigkeit der
wissenschaften auf alle bereiche
begrenzen dass es eine bewegung
jetzt gibt es innerhalb dieses weltbild
therapeutischen ansatzes den sie pflegen
noch ein zweites jetzt heißt das heißt
nämlich nicht nur dass die wissenschaft
genau beschreibt wie die wirklichkeit
erschaffen es sondern es gibt eine
besondere wissenschaft die neuronale
wissenschaft die sagt alles was wir
erfahren ist nur eine simulation unseres
gehirns und das sagt uns die
wissenschaft auch blödsinn
das ist reiner blödsinn weil das lehrt
nicht die neuro und
kognitionswissenschaften die
neurowissenschaft kann im besten fall
und das ist sehr nützlich ja erforschen
welche neuronalen muster hier
instanziert sind was hängt mit was genau
zusammen und welche mentalen phänomene
sind womit korreliert ja also wenn man
da und da drückt kann man plötzlich
nicht mehr sprechen oder wenn ihr etwas
ausfällt ist man gelähmt das kann man
alles zum glück feststellen und
medizinisch fruchtbar machen
daraus folgt aber nicht dass etwa
sprechen identisch ist mit dem broker
real oder irgend so etwas ja oder seen
mit dem visuellen kortex
oder die moral da vorne sitzt aber nicht
daraus dass alles was ich im moment
erfahre was ich im moment das was der
zuschauer im moment erfährt da diese
sendung sieht ist ein effekt seines
gehirns ohne dieses gehirns würde alters
nicht erfahren ja also es ist völlig
richtig ohne geeignet das gehirn das
übrigens natürlich in einem mehr oder
weniger vollständigen organismus
eingebettet seien wichtig für sehen ja
nur die gehirne selbst machen es gar
nicht wenn ein das sowieso nicht also
dass es sogar naturwissenschaftlich
falsch denn gehirne sind wesentlich teil
vom ganzen lebewesen ja die sind schon
eingebettet aber auch wenn wir das in
rechnung stellen ist es ja so dass wenn
ich etwas erkenne die zuschauerin zum
beispiel gerade uns sehen ja dann
funktioniert das nur deswegen weil sie
eine beziehung zu uns haben die
simulieren ja nicht uns sondern das
gehirn leistet selbstverständlich einen
beitrag zur erkenntnis der wirklichkeit
aber im fall der wahrnehmung gehört zur
wirklichkeit eben sehr viel mehr als das
gehirn zum beispiel sie wenn ich sie
gerade sind sie nicht in meinem gehirn
es gibt nirgends ein bild von ihnen mein
gehirn egal was sie hier suchen sie
werden kein bild von ihnen ist das
müsste sich eine weitere person in
meinem gehirn überhaupt anschauen um ein
bild sein zu können da wird noch genau
außerdem sind viele probleme wesentlich
natürlich noch nicht gelöst also das
angesprochene um musculus problem zum
beispiel also der mann im gehirn der
wieder ein mann im gehirn braucht und
dann immer so weiter genau das sind also
zu viele so viel platz haben wir nicht
ja dann müssten wir unendlich viel
speicherkapazität
eine wahl ist dieses problem zu
schildern ist ja und das ist so ganz
gängig kann man sagen das problem wie
kommt das glas ins gehirn machen
irgendwie das passt nicht so richtig
rein und sie sagen die frage ist an sich
schon vollkommen falsch gestellt weil
man kann sagen ist eine ausgangsfrage
der philosophie wie kommt die welt ins
gehirn und wie adäquat ist das bild der
welt in genau das ist schon völlig
falsch formuliert also natürlich
brauchen wir wenn ich recht habe auch
gewisse revisionen bezüglich der frage
was das gehirn tut ja also eine metapher
die ich für richtig halte die man
natürlich eine theorie übersetzen muss
wäre der gedanke dass das gehirn der
empfänger ist von wirklichkeit und nicht
der produzent wie das der amerikanische
philosoph mark johnston einmal
ausgedrückt hat das heißt so viel wie ja
also stellen sie sich das vor wie ne wie
jetzt eben das endgerät auf dem sie uns
sehen das endgerät produziert uns nicht
sondern das empfängt eine von ihm
unabhängig existierende wirklichkeit als
bildformat und so kann man auch das
gehirn verstehen des gehirns
sozusagen teile der wirklichkeit an ja
es wird sozusagen in der wirklichkeit
die ganze zeit gesendet
ja und das gehirn ist nur unser zugriff
auf die sendung sowie ein endgerät aber
das gehirn macht ja auch viel bist es
fügt etwas hinzu es lässt etwas weg es
reduziert die komplexität das heißt es
verfälscht doch auch das was es empfängt
das würde ich deswegen nicht so sagen
weil das gehirn eben eigentlich nichts
verfälscht ja also wenn ich jetzt die
müller lea illusion habe also diese
optische vision die wir gerade sagen
genau oder irgendeine andere optische
illusion ja dann ist es natürlich so
dass die erklärung dafür dass gewisse
tiere wie menschen ja opfer solcher
illusionen werden
dazu braucht man zum beispiel
neurowissenschaften oder andere formen
der psychologie um das zu erklären
aber das heißt natürlich überhaupt nicht
dass hier irgendetwas verfälscht wird
sondern das gehirn ja formatiert oder
sie regiert viel mehr informationen auf
eine bestimmte weise wir kriegen ein
ausschnitt der wirklichkeit ja an der
das an der das gehirn klarerweise
beteiligt ist in diesem fall aber wir
können das ja korrigieren verfälschungen
würde ja bedeuten dass wir sozusagen
nicht hinter den bildschirm kommen ja
dann werden wir opfer einer simulation
sind wir aber nicht in ihrem buch ist
aber auch der gedanke wichtig dass das
gehirn die wirklichkeit nicht wie ein
spiegel abbildet sondern dass unser
insel in der welt seien immer schon
überschüssig ist wir fügen etwas hinzu
wir positionieren uns und die welt das
heißt das gehirn ist kein spiegel kein
betreuer sondern eine art maschine die
wirklichkeit zu gehen auf eigene weise
schafft also ist es nicht nur das gehirn
sondern natürlich eine ganze sprache und
andere übungen bei menschen menschen
sind ja soziale lebewesen das heißt wir
können nur deswegen imaginieren ja also
fiktionen produzieren weil wir teil sind
komplexer gemeinschaft wir lernen
erzählungen zu hause ja kein gehirn ist
allein kein gehirn ist allein kein
einziges menschliches gehirn würde
jemals den zustand eines
erwachsenenalters erreichen wenn nicht
andere menschen da wären die in unser
gehirn eingreifen von außen wenn ich
jetzt mit ihnen spreche zb verändere ich
natürlich die elektro elektrizitäts
ströme sowie maxi verändert mein gehirn
ganz rechnung durch sprechen und sie
meine und wir zusammen gerade die
gehirne unserer zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer ja und diese magie die müssen
wir mit in rechnung stellen
das gehirn ist eben teil hochkomplexer
kausaler umgehen
und dazu gehören aber auch geistige
zustände zum beispiel mein wunsch ja
jetzt in diesem gespräch klar
darzustellen was ich zu sagen habe
gehört ja auch dazu dass unsere beiden
gehirne jetzt in einem bestimmten
zustand sind aber der wunsch ist da
draußen der wirklichkeit nicht zu finden
der ist an sie gebunden an die person
die sie sind ja aber ich bin ja da
draußen in der wirklichkeit ja okay
jetzt habe ich es verstanden jetzt
wissen wir auch warum gehirne nicht
denken können die brauchen einen laib
sie brauchen andere gehirne und sie
brauchen die wirklichkeit was ist denn
eigentlich man fragt sich wo das ist
klar genug so interessant und so
furchtbar attraktiv an dieser
vorherrschenden weltbild stimmung dass
es die gehirne sind ja alles machen kann
sagen gar kein attraktiver gedanken
offenbar scheint das für viele gerade zu
sexy zu sein
ja das würde ich jetzt eben neo
existenzialistisch folgendermaßen
erklären ja menschen wollen sich mit
einem ding in der wirklichkeit
identifizieren das ist die alte idee die
der philosoph seneca well folgendermaßen
wunderbar auf den punkt gebracht hat ein
amerikanischer philosoph der jüngst
verstorben ist muss man sah ja genau
ständig bringt das so auf den punkt
nichts ist menschlicher als der wunsch
kein mensch zu sein
das heißt wir suchen immer nach
irgendetwas mit dem wir uns
identifizieren können das nicht wir
selbst sind das kann eben eine
unsterbliche seele sein dann hält man
sich auch für etwas anderes als man ist
oder sein gehirn
ich bin schlichtweg nicht mit meinem
gehirn identisch wäre ein falscher satz
ich bin ja vieles mehr als mein gehirn
aber mich mit meinem gehirn zu
identifizieren dass viele menschen tun
hat den vorteil mich von meiner freiheit
zu entlassen das ist eine flucht vor der
eigenen ausgesetzt haid die man mit
solchen fantasien verbindet ganz genau
wir haben man flieht vor der freiheit
und rettet sich in den gedanken dass man
ein ding unter dingen ist gott der
physikalisch muss als solches reduziert
und falsch denn in euroland ismus ist
falsch jetzt gibt es gleichsam als
unsinns kirsche auf diesem weltbild
kuchen noch ein drittes theorie und das
sehr attraktives das heißt nämlich was
menschen tun mit ihrem gehirn und ihrem
bleibt nichts anderes als rechnen
das gehirn ist ein computer und der
computer ist ein gehirn und damit sind
allerlei utopische hoffnungen verbunden
die upload barkeit es ist auf eine
festplatte und sterblichkeit denkt
simulation das ist für sie geradezu
die krönung des schwachsinns wenn ich
das richtig sehe ja genau das ist
ziemlich grober unsinn ja die sogenannte
komposition ahler theorie des geistes
nicht also wie sie schon gesagt haben
das gehirn als computer also computer
sind ja zunächst einmal theoretische
modelle also modelle aus der
theoretischen informatik das wurde
entwickelt wie wir wissen die moderne
informatik von alan turing da hat uns
gesagt was ein computer ist ursprünglich
ist ja ein computer ein mensch stellt
das berechnet in einem büro das heißt
das wort computer im englischen zunächst
und touring hat dann den begriff eines
computers geprägt alan turing ist ein
berühmter mathematiker der die
grundlagen für das was wir heute
computer nennen gesetzt hat ganz genau
und dabei ist es ihnen gelungen ja
bestimmte mathematische modelle zu
formulieren die viel leisten können wie
wir sehen in unserem computerzeitalter
keine frage und die kann man dann
umsetzen in einer hardware mittels der
entwicklung von chips und halbleiter
forschung und was man dann eben tut ja
in den ingenieurswissenschaften
das heißt aber natürlich überhaupt nicht
dass unser gehirn ein computer ist ja
also zunächst einmal denn wer unter
einem computer ein system verstehen dass
software und hardware besteht dann sind
computer ja von menschen hergestellt
industriell gehirn und aber das heißt ja
nicht dass sie nicht denken könnten
naja also wenn man unter denken versteht
zunächst einmal das haben vom gedanken
ja dann würde ich sagen sind computer
wie wir sie heute kennen ja also ob das
jetzt smartphones sind oder naheliegende
demnächst vielleicht existierende
quantencomputer überhaupt gar keine
denker von irgendetwas ja aber jetzt
könnte man sagen wenn ein computer wenn
es wackelt wie eine ente wenn es
quietscht wie eine ente und wenn es
schwimmt wie eine ente das heißt mein
computer all das tun was menschen auch
tun dann ist es eine internet denken die
halt ja das würde ich tatsächlich nicht
sagen ja also ihre um zum anderen
vergleich zu bringen mit einer
beinprothese sehr gut dass wir so etwas
haben ja mit einer beinprothese kann
nicht laufen wenn ich mein bein
verlieren
das heißt aber nicht dass ich jetzt ein
neues bein habe sondern ich habe eben
eine beinprothese mit einem smartphone
kann ich gewisse dinge tun zb schnelle
einfache gleichungen ausrechnen oder
lösungen für schacht probleme finden auf
die ich sonst nie gekommen wäre
das heißt aber nicht dass mein computer
oder mein taschenrechner denkt sondern
es heißt dass ich mit meinem
taschenrechner denke und dadurch mich
selbst verbessert habe wie mit einer
prothese ein instrument unseres denkens
ganz genau wir denken im computer nicht
denkt der computer von
ich ja das tun wir es an ihnen den
schönen satz das war für mich wirklich
ein aha-erlebnis computer denken genauso
wenig wie die donau die idee dass die
donau die innenperspektive hat ist
genauso erich wie das computer sie haben
genau die donau ist auch ein
hochkomplexes system wenn man die sich
um 1 und dann die ganzen moleküle die da
eine rolle spielen das leben das sich in
der donau entfaltet die geschichte des
flusses hochkomplexes system das uns
sehr beeindrucken kann
aber wir würden ja nicht denken da ist
sozusagen jemand zuhause und warum
denken wir eigentlich dass im smartphone
einer stecken könnte also jetzt
vielleicht noch nicht aber sozusagen
demnächst das halte ich für eine sehr
unbegründete fantasie die wir haben
woher weiß ich denn das bei ihnen jemand
zu hause ist ja da gibt es den schönen
alten wunderbaren satz des chinesischen
philosophen drang zu der ich weiß nicht
mehr mit wem auf der brücke steht in
seinem rücken in dieser berühmten szene
und zwang so sagt schau mal was der
fisch für empfindungen hat und sein
gesprächspartner sagt wo er weiß denn du
dass der fisch empfindungen hat worauf
drang zu sagt wer weiß denn du dass ich
das nicht weiß ja das heißt ich würde
sagen wir wissen tatsächlich durch
evolutionäre anpassungsmechanismen die
mehrere hunderttausend jahre bei
menschen in anspruch genommen haben dass
andere lebewesen bei bewusstsein sind
wir haben eine tun nimmt also eine
einstellung auf mehr oder weniger der
gleichen wellenlänge mit vielen
lebewesen insbesondere und säugetieren
und irgendwann geht das aus da wissen
wir nicht mehr weiter aber das ist ja
das problem des fremd psychischen wie
man das in der philosophie nennt und er
bleibt auch eine lücke ich weiß davon
meinen gedanken in unmittelbarerer weise
oder von meinem geschmack von wasser in
anderer weise als wenn sie wasser
trinken das ist immer nur eine analogie
ich sehe es auf andere weise ich muss es
schließen bei mir selbst ist es immer da
ja da bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher
bei sich selbst gibt es nicht bei
manchen mentalen zustand muss man
ausschließen also jemand kann über
jemand anderes besser wissen dass er
depressiv oder verliebt ist also nicht
mehr selbst daran sehen wir schon dass
wir nicht irgendwie die autorität über
unsere eigenen gedanken haben die man
sich manchmal zuschreibt daran sieht man
das oder ich kann sagen vorsicht das
schmeckt bitter wenn ich da eben zitrone
rein getan habe und dann weiß ich schon
wie es für sie schmecken wird ja das
heißt ich habe von außen zugriff auf
ihre inneren zuständen und sie hier auf
meine deswegen glaube ich gibt es in
wirklichkeit kein problem des fremd
fischen
das ist ein klassisches philosophisch
ein problem das man auflösen
wir haben jetzt schon viele scheinen
probleme korting zu gabriel so wie sie
die welt sehen er aufgelöst
die subjekt objekt spannung ist falsch
der physikalisch muss ist falsch der
neuron allis muss ist falsch der
digitalis muss ist falsch wenn ich mir
jetzt die forschungsprogramme weltweit
milliardenfach ansehen dann fließt genau
in diese programme ein unglaubliches
geld wie kommt das wenn es so klar ist
dass es eigentlich unsinn ist na ja das
liegt daran dass wir der philosophie als
wissenschaft nicht den raum einräumen
die sie bräuchte in einer modernen
aufgeklärten gesellschaft wir haben in
den letzten 200 jahren der
industrialisierung variante einer
moderne den philosophischen fortschritt
entkoppelt vom naturwissenschaftlich
technologischen und wir sehen ja was
dieses weltbild uns eingebracht hat das
hat uns an den rand der selbstzerstörung
gefahr es ist doch ein philosophisches
wenn ich meine man könnte ja sagen sie
versuchen die philosophie als die große
retterin zu installieren aber sie sagen
gleichzeitig sie es auch die große
sünderin es ist die philosophie die uns
auf den falschen weg gebracht hat ja
haben sie denn jetzt wirklich die wunde
heilen die sie selbst geschlagen hat ja
nur das kann tatsächlich meines
erachtens nur die philosophie aber die
philosophie muss sich genauso weiter
entwickeln wie wir das für andere
wissenschaften auch gesehen haben dass
die philosophie muss auch geradezu
buchstäblich einen quantensprung machen
ja und sie auf die theoretische höhe der
gegenwart begeben deswegen müssen
philosophen und philosophin natürlich
auch in interdisziplinären teams
forschen ja aber immer mit denselben
ansprüchen die jetzt physiker oder
soziologinnen auch haben würden also mit
dem versuch die wirklichkeit zu erkennen
ja und nicht einfach immer nur in die
geschichte der philosophie zu schauen
oder zu schauen was gerade sonstwo
geschrieben wurde um dann festzustellen
was der meinung stand es noch so graffy
das machen leider viele philosophien und
philosophen die hinken hinterher die
sind diener der wissenschaften aber
keine kritiker ganz genau wir müssen auf
augenhöhe kooperieren mit den anderen
wissenschaften aber natürlich auch mit
wirtschaft politik zivilgesellschaft
kunst und religion das ist fortschritt
der menschheit
aber jeder hält das was er gerade tut
für das wichtigste das gilt für den
biologen für den ökonom für den physiker
es gilt auch für den philosophen der
anspruch den sie mit ihrer eigenen
tätigkeit verbinden ist gern sehr
umfassender weil sie sagen den anderen
wissenschaften eigentlich was sie
eigentlich tun
anders gefragt ist das nicht eine art
überschätzung der philosophie in ihrer
rolle die philosophie in dem modell dass
sich entwickler oder in den vielen
modellen ja moderiert das heißt ich sage
nicht den anderen was sie tun müssen
sondern ich versuche zunächst einmal zu
verstehen was sie tun und das andante um
das dann einzusortieren in den zustand
des heutigen wissens ja also als
erkenntnis theoretiker beschäftige ich
mich ja mit dem wissen also ich frage
mich was wissen ist und da andere auch
wissens ansprüche erheben und teils sehr
erfolgreich muss sich die einbauen
natürlich in mein konzept des wissens
das muss integriert werden ist ein
integriertes bild und in diesem
integrierten bild kommt es dann darauf
an richtig die wirklichkeit zu sortieren
in der form einer ontologie also nicht
als diktator sondern als moderator der
wissenschaften ganz genau das ist der
große unterschied ja ich gehe ja nicht
zu den physikern und sage ihnen
sozusagen welche vereinheitlichte
künftige physik die richtige ist quanten
schleifen gravitation oder was auch
immer mir am besten gefällt sondern ich
gehe hin und versuche erst einmal zu
verstehen und dann zu moderieren und wo
aber philosophische klarerweise
philosophische ansprüche erhoben werden
die sich tarnen als nicht so scharf da
springe ich ein und sagen bis hierhin
und nicht weiter das rote fähnchen und
sagen so geht es nicht genau das würde
ja auch der chemiker tun oder der
virologe wenn ich jetzt auftrete und
hätte meinungen über die nukleotide des
bikes des corona virus werden mich die
virologen korrigieren und sagen was weiß
denn der aber es gibt ja schon
unterschied weil die philosophie als
mutter wissenschaft die frage hat was es
zu tun gibt und was es nicht gibt was
existiert und nicht existiert die
ontologie können wir sagen und ihre
philosophie heißt nicht umsonst fiktion
weil sie nähern sich dieser frage was es
gibt und nicht gibt nicht über die
vordertür die sagen nicht existieren
personen existieren universitäten
existieren sondern sie fragen sich was
existiert eigentlich nicht durch die
hintertür gleich sagen was wissen wir
eigentlich über nichtexistenz und eine
der überraschenden auch verwirrenden
folgerungen in ihrer philosophie heißt
weihnachtsmänner madame bovary und das
raumschiff enterprise existiert genauso
wie die universität zürich zürich und
wie die bundesrepublik deutschland
richtig richtig genau man muss nur sagen
ja kleine korrektur
wir haben heute in 6 12
es ist ja der mann werden geschenke den
gibt es wirklich richtig also genau den
gibt es tatsächlich und zwar als
gegenstand ästhetischer erfahrung ja als
gegenstand menschlicher ein bildungs
praktiken gibt es den weihnachtsmann
diaz an klaus wie er heißt und dieser
weihnachtsmann den wir hier haben ja
oder den nikolaus der gerade vor vor mir
steht der löst in mir kulturelles
gedächtnis aus das heißt ich stelle mir
allerlei dabei vor was man so als kind
umso weiter erlebt hat und sich
eingebildet hat und das wird ausgelöst
durch diesen gegenstand dieser
gegenstand da ist natürlich nicht mit
dem nikolaus identisch sondern das ist
nur der anlass für ein wurscht das ist
ein bild von einer vorstellung genau
aber ist das nicht einfach nur eine
komplizierte weise zu sagen dass es
ihnen halt wirklich dann doch nicht gibt
nein das ist das ist in der tat wenn man
so will eine komplizierte weise um den
satz der weihnachtsmann existiert nicht
richtig zu verstehen denn hier ist ein
altes tiefes rätsel das die philosophie
überhaupt zur weltbild formation
gebracht hat ja das rätsel geht zurück
auf den philosophen parmenides und ich
nenne das deswegen das elegische rätsel
weil der bürgermeister der stadt elia
war heute wählen
sagen sie mal wusste stets das rätsel
geht so ja wie kann ich von etwas was
nicht existiert sagen das ist nicht
existiert ohne dass es dadurch existiert
also wenn ich sage der weihnachtsmann
existiert nicht beziehe ich mich mit dem
wort der weihnachtsmann ja auf den
weihnachtsmann und sage vom
weihnachtsmann war etwas war objektiv
war es gibt die nicht es gibt ihn wie
kann das sein
ja und wie kann das sein denn jetzt muss
ihn ja geben damit ich über ihn sagen
dass er nicht existiert das ist das
rätsel und dieses rätsel lösen durch die
sogenannte sennfeld ontologie das heißt
der weihnachtsmann existiert sehr wohl
zum beispiel in erzählung und
einbildungen träumen hoffnungen von
kindern usw
aber der weihnachtsmann existiert zum
beispiel nicht in zürich das hat
konsequenzen er bringt den kindern auch
keine geschenke in zürich nein nein
leider nicht also liebe kinder
bitte nicht zu hören meine müssen jetzt
ausschalten also sie sagen dass in einer
philosophischen weise er ist unlogisch
isoliert es gibt eine welt die wir
selbst geschaffen haben einer zelle welt
in denen der weihnachtsmann existiert
und es ist richtig zu sagen das hat
darin existiert aber diese welt zeichnet
sich dadurch aus dass es keinen kausalen
kontakt zwischen der welt die wir beide
bewohnen geben und der welt das
weihnachtssingen ganz genau der
weihnachtsmann ist wie ich
ganz woanders ja der weihnachtsmann ist
so weit weg von uns dass wir eigentlich
auch nicht vernünftig über ihn
nachdenken können deswegen auch das
kuddelmuddel an erzählen aber er ist
nicht nur in unserem kopf nein nein nein
er ist sogar gar nicht nur in unserem
kopf wir brauchen unseren kopf und
unseren geist um uns den weihnachtsmann
zu nähern
ja wir kommen aber niemals ganz nah an
deswegen darf sich jeder oder jede von
uns den weihnachtsmann ein bisschen
anders vorstellen sie haben jetzt kinder
auch in der jüngere tochter
sie fragt jetzt ihre tochter franzi papa
du bist doch philosophie gibt es eine
hörner wirklich und sie antworten ja
antworten sie das wirklich
die diskussion führe ich tatsächlich oft
unschöne quaddeln worden sind tolles
einräumt meine antwort darauf ist ja es
gibt einen hörner zum beispiel im film
das letzte einhorn dann aber meine
tochter natürlich wissen möchte sind ja
auch gefährlich können hier vorbeikommen
oder kann ich auf den reiten und dann
sage ich nein und das drücken wir
alltags sprachlich natürlich so aus dass
wir sagen weihnachtsmänner oder 100 gibt
es wie sie das nennt nicht in echt und
das ist ganz wichtig ja aber es gibt die
einbildungen in echt in denen sie
vorkommen
aber man sagt es gibt etwas in echter
hat man doch einen horizont von
wirklichen im spiel
zum beispiel dann was die wissenschaft
fest stellt man könnte ja sagen in ihrer
welt gibt es gar nichts in echt es gibt
je nach sinn feld verschiedene dinge und
die formulierung in echt ist sinnlos
richtig weil in echt wenn in echt sagen
soll es gibt eine was gibt es da
wirklich keine mehr sind da sind die
wirklichen wirklichen die jahren ja ja
das ist ein irrtum weil nicht wenn wir
versuchen diese kategorie zu bilden zu
sagen da was ist denn dann die
wirklichkeit wo die wirklich wirklichen
dinge drin sind dann kriegen wir darauf
keine gute antwort sondern irgendwie da
so etwas wie die naturwissenschaften
sagen was da drin ist oder der common
sense
also das ist die so genannte sind sind
fällt und logie ffo wie sie das nennen
und es gibt zum beispiel das sichtfeld
des fußballspiels da gibt es rote karten
gibt es im richtigen leben nicht angibt
dass das umfeld der demokratischen
wahlen
da kann man seine stimme abgeben das
gibt es nicht überall wie viel sinn
felder würden sie sagen gibt es denn so
also mehr als unendlich viele also weil
das nicht absehbar ist also transfer
nicht viele um es genau zu sagen also
wie gesagt oder anders gewendet in
definiert viele egal wie viele sinn
felder sie namhaft machen es wird immer
noch mehr geben mindestens das sinn feld
in dem sie jetzt die anderen aufgezählt
haben und da sehen sie ja sie geraten
sofort in regresse das
dass sie werden immer weiter sinn felder
zählen ja damit werden wir prinzipiell
nicht fertig und ich habe versucht dafür
noch beweise zu führen dass die sinn
feld ontologie so ähnlich das kennt man
aus der mathematischen mengenlehre ja
dass wir eben dass man zeigen kann dass
es mehr als unendlich viele also über
abziehbarkeit das hat was mit
mathematischen eigenschaften zu tun sind
felder gibt kurzum in aller kürze
unendlich viele und jetzt gibt es einen
sinn feld und das ist das spektakuläre
sie haben auch darüber ein buch
geschrieben
es lautet die welt gibt es nicht es gibt
nicht das sinn fällt aller sind fällt es
gibt nicht den großen behälter der alle
sind felder in sich beinhaltet deswegen
gibt es die welt nicht es gibt nur
selten können tragen genau das kann man
ganz einfach anhand der situation auf
diesem tisch illustrieren
wenn jetzt jemand vorbei kommt und man
zeigt auf den tisch und fragt wie viele
gegenstände befinden sich auf dem tisch
dann würden menschen vielleicht die
gläser zählen und die bücher oder die
blätter und aber warum ist denn zb das
glas ein gegenstand ein einziger und
nicht zum beispiel viele ich konnte auch
die moleküle hier zählen das heißt in
einem sinn fällt das gerade hier vor mir
ist auf diesem tisch
ja gibt es zum beispiel drei wenn ich
nur die zelle drei gegenstände glas
glasflasche aber wenn ich es moleküle
zählen wir sind vielmehr sind es
vielmehr so und was ich jetzt sage ist
dass es nicht eine wirklichkeit gibt die
darüber entscheidet wie wir insgesamt
richtig zählen
sie können die moleküle zellen oder die
gläser zellen und in beiden fällen
werden sie die wirklichkeit erkennen
nicht aber sind die moleküle wirklicher
als die gläser ein philosoph der
kürzlich zu gast war der zürcher
philosoph michael lampert er hat etwas
ganz ähnliches gesagt das schauen wir
uns mal kurz einem einspieler
man kann wenn man wissenschaftlich
ästhetisch und vielleicht auch meditativ
die zustände in denen man ist und in
denen irgendein welt gegenstand ist
lange genug analysiert zu der
überzeugung kommen
diese analyse ist kann man ins
unendliche treiben sie hört nie auf
statt zu einem kern zu kommen komme ich
zu immer weiteren schichten also die
elementarteilchenphysik a schein auch
diese erfahrung zu machen das einen
immer grösseren beschleuniger brauchen
weil es in dem was man eigentlich
einfacher einfach ist immer noch
strukturen gibt die man finden
das heißt egal welche beschreibung wir
von der welt wählen es gibt dahinter
immer noch eine weitere beschreibung und
weiteren beschreibung ist eine art
bodenlosigkeit ein treibsand der
erkenntnis dass verbindet man kann nicht
mit realismus wie sie es eigentlich
nennen ja also ich bin mit dem was
michael hampe eben gesagt hat völlig
einverstanden auch und dieses phänomen
versuche ich mit der sinn feld ontologie
zu modellieren ja also es gibt kein
tiefstes level der wirklichkeit und in
der tat in der physik macht man genau
auf diese erfahrung und selbst wenn es
da wäre könnten wir nicht feststellen
dass wir es erreicht haben und realismus
heißt jetzt aber hier dass das was wir
dabei erkennen ja also zum beispiel auf
dem weg der analyse des universums
wirklich ist wir finden dort elektronen
da sind wirklich elektronen das heißt
realismus heißt in diesem spezifischen
fall das folgende unsere theorien können
wahr oder falsch seien und ob sie wahr
oder falsch sind hängt nicht nur von den
theorien ab das ist sozusagen die
kürzeste zusammenfasst sondern auch von
der welt sondern auch von der
wirklichkeit genau ich sage natürlich
nicht welt sondern nicht von dem was der
fall ist es nie wieder tun
jetzt sind ja nicht nur erkennen gewesen
die die welt so erkennen wollen wir
handeln ja auch in ihr und wir handeln
nach gut und böse nach dingen die wir
tun sollen und die wir nicht tun sollen
jetzt gibt es in ihrer anthologie in den
flow sowie ein satz der ihn sehr wichtig
ist nämlich moralische tatsachen gibt es
und sie gibt es nicht nur lokal für eine
kultur für eine zeit sondern universal
für alles was menschen sind moralisch
tatsachen gibt es überall
ja genau also ich versteh zunächst
einmal unter einer moralischen tatsache
einen wahren satz darüber was wir tun
beziehungsweise unterlassen sollen
lediglich insofern wir menschen sind ja
also sofern wir menschen sind gibt es
etwa was wir gibt es vieles was wir
einander schulen also für hunde bieber
und dachse nicht für menschen genau
vorsicht aber genau ich leite daraus
natürlich theoretische und umwelt hin
diese ansprüche ab also weil wir
diejenigen lebewesen sind die zuhörer
moralität also moralischer einsicht in
universaler tatsachen befähigt sind
genau deswegen haben wir extrem viele
pflichten gegenüber anderen lebewesen
und der nicht belebten natur
was sind denn jetzt moralische tatsachen
nennen sie mal drei also das einfachste
beispiel das dann an der stelle immer
kommt ist so etwas wie du sollst keine
kinder grundlos foltern ja also ich
würde sagen
als keine kinder folgten aber noch
einmal mit gründen dürfte man nein eben
nicht aber deswegen kann man den satz
nicht so kann man leicht unendlich viele
moralische tatsachen und generieren du
sollst keine kinder um sieben uhr
morgens foltern usw
aber auch andere du sollst möglichst
viele menschen durch den einsatz
geeigneter methoden vor schweren cobit
19 erkrankungen schützen ja du sollst
alles dafür tun dass keine diktatur auf
planet erde entsteht und so weit wie
sollst nicht töten klar ja du sollst
nicht töten ja würde ich auch dazu
zählen wie sollst vater und mutter ihren
nein
woran erkennt man denn das etwas eine
moralische tatsache ist und nicht es
gibt ja nun leute die halten das für
schwierig sie sagen im gegenteil ist es
ganz einfach genau es gibt moralisch
offensichtlich ist wie du sollst keine
kinder foltern und dann gibt es
komplexer moralische tatsachen bei denen
wir nicht sofort eine antwort wissen ja
also nicht wir haben das ja gerade der
pandemie oder angesichts der grossen
klimakatastrophe auf die wir zu steuern
dort haben wir es zu tun mit komplexen
situationen die komplexität der
situation besteht aber darin dass wir
die nicht moralischen tatsachen noch
nicht alle kennen ja wenn wir alles
wüssten sozusagen über das komplexe
system planet erde ja dann wüssten wir
glaube ich auch was wir aus umwelt
ethischen gründen tun wir aber das heißt
ja wenn wir wissen werden wissen wir was
zu tun wäre jetzt sind wir menschen wir
sind gerade nicht allwissend also bleibt
das problem das problem bleibt zwar
natürlich wie in allen wissens
ansprüchen müssen der gründe dafür
finden warum wir etwas bestimmtes
glauben und in praktischen fragen damit
natürlich auch tun
ja es gibt also moralischen fortschritt
wie ich das auch in meinem buch nenne
moralischer fortschritt besteht darin
dass wir partiell verdeckte moralische
wahrheiten ans licht ziehen ja
moralische weiten sind häufig auch nur
partiell verdeckt nicht also sklaverei
war immer schon moralisch verwerflich
auch zu zeiten des aristoteles man hätte
nur die sklaven fragen müssen oder die
sklavin und sexuelle belästigung von
frauen etwa oder sexuelle gewalt
gegenüber frauen die in der
vergangenheit häufiger opfer waren
sexualisierter gewalt war auch schon
immer moralisch weiß dass ich auch gegen
jeden kulturrelativismus man sagt man
den chinesen ist das moralisch richtig
bei uns ist es falsch markus gabriel
zieht er den großen rasierer an und
sagte es gibt eine moral die gilt für
alle menschen und mit diesem ganzen
kulturellen relativismus da täuscht ihr
euch dann macht ihr ein riesenfehler ein
fehler für die menschheit genau einen
brandgefährlichen für
naja weil wenn wir uns in moralischen
fragen so grundlegend täuschen und etwa
glauben dass es eine andere moral in
china gibt als in was ich finnland ja
wenn wir einen solchen falschen gedanken
haben dann gefährdet uns dass wir als
menschheit denn in praktischen ethischen
fragen der selbstbestimmung des
menschlichen lebewesens ja ziehen wir ja
gigantische konsequenzen wir tun ja
etwas und unter umständen schadenwehr
menschen weil wir ein falsches bild
davon haben dass die sozusagen in ihrer
kultur fest hb sind sie ein weißer mann
noch nicht alt aber sie werden
irgendwann auch sein
sie kommen aus gutem hause sie leben in
zentraleuropa ist könnte man sagen da
kommt dieser bonner philosoph mit seinem
universalismus das ist nichts anderes
als die fortführung des kolonialismus
mit philosophischen mitteln der wirt
sein weltbild für alle das ist schon
deswegen unsinn weil kolonialismus aus
moralisch universalen gründen moralisch
verwerflich könnten sich ja darüber
täuschen was sie eigentlich tun
na ja aber das ist ja erst mal hat das
das logische niveau einer verschwörungs
ernennung ja also wenn ich jetzt so
etwas sage wie das imperialismus oder
sexualisierte gewalt gegen trans
personen moralisch verwerflich ist dann
wird das ja nicht dadurch wahr oder
falsch dass ich das sage sondern das ist
ja zum beispiel etwas was man gelernt
hat in seinem leben ja also früher
dachten menschen imperialismus auch kein
problem man müsse die geht irgendwie
fortgeschrittene zivilisation irgendwem
bringen und haben dadurch gräueltaten
gerechtfertigt das haben wir irgendwann
erkannt dass das die rechtfertigung von
gräueltaten ist und damit das ist völlig
klar dass so etwas wie kolonialismus
oder sexualisierte gewalt gegen sachen
einmal trans personen moral aber werfe
ich recht und zwar universal das hat mit
mir nichts zu tun
diese rede vom moralischen tatsachen sie
scheint mir sehr bedeutsam ich gebe auch
zu ich würde gern daran glauben
es bleiben aber noch einige probleme für
mich zum beispiel ich kann hier erkennen
dass das ein tisch ist dass es eine
tatsache wie ein glas die moralischen
tatsachen sind nicht so greifbar die
sind in anderer weise in der welt woran
erkenne ich denn die haben die haben die
ihn ein fähnchen wo sie sagt hallo ich
bin der moralischen woran mit welchen
sinn erkennen wir die ja das ist
eigentlich ganz einfach also das was man
traditionell das gewissen genannt hat
das ist nur über theoretisiert deswegen
würde ich das so mal nicht nennen also
die situation in der wir uns gerade
befinden hat wie ich das nenne eine
moralische ladung ja das heißt ich weiß
dass ich gewisse dinge ja in unserem
gespräch jetzt natürlich gar nicht tun
soll aus moralischen gründen
inan ohren ziehen oder irgend so etwas
weil das setting das nicht hergibt genau
dass ich spüre das ja dafür brauche ich
keine große kognitive anstrengend ist
das anerzogen natürlich lernen wir ja
moralische tatsachen zu erkennen eine
gute erziehung besteht im idealfall
darin dass wir wie alles tot lust das
genannt hat den ottos logos also die
richtige einsicht erlangen und das
wollen wir voneinander lernen zu einer
guten erziehung gehört aber
selbstverständlich auch dass wir etwas
von unseren kindern lernen der gedanke
ist natürlich nicht dass wir ein immer
schon feststehen das wissen über die
generation transportieren sondern dass
wir im gespräch auch mit unseren kindern
die wir in den logos hinein holen also
in das spiel des lebens und verlangt von
gründen dass wir uns darüber austauschen
was das moralisch richtiges also es gibt
etwas in uns bei uns klar menschsein
eine art sinn gefühl dafür was gut und
richtig ist und wenn es nicht verstellt
ist kann das jeder aktivieren ganz genau
das ist die andere ja mal ein beispiel
nicht aus deutschland aus dem anderen
kulturkreis ein ein mitglied des
indianerstammes der crew die sich auch
selber indianer nennen lernt dass es gut
ist dies jux umzubringen
die xerox mehr länder lernen dass von
den projekts ein junger mann recht sein
bruder skalpiert 1 yorks er tut damit
genau das was ihm seine innere stimme
sagt selbst die xerox würden sagen hatte
eigentlich richtig gemacht wenn wir das
jetzt aber beschreiben hatte einen
unschuldigen umgebracht die beiden
individuen die betroffen sind würden
sagen das war moralisch vollkommen okay
sind die verstellt bis zur blindheit
oder müssen wir einfach sagen die haben
einen anderen sinn
ich glaube wenn man denen der skalpiert
wird fragt ja deswegen ich glaube es ist
nicht so verstellt man frage den der
skalpiert aber den satz noch sagen na ja
gut wir sind mit dem gros feinde und das
ist innerhalb des reglements unseres
beziehung vollkommen okay da hat das so
gemacht wie ein nach allen regeln der
kunst die wir beide ehren
ich glaube wenn sie jemand der wirklich
gerade skalpiert wird fragen ja ja schön
ist das nicht das ist klar aber es wäre
ja auch ehren verletzend wenn man nichts
kapiert würde wenn man unterlegen wäre
wenn sie ihn dann fragen aber sagen es
bitte dass du rettest meine ehre mein
selbstbild du handelst nach den regeln
eines stammes dann würde ich jetzt an
der stelle in der diskussion als
nächstes weiter fragen stopp was ist
denn ehre
ja da
natürlich würde ich der meinung sein
dass beide in dem fall einer täuschung
unterliegen ja wie konnte ich das auch
sonst beurteilen
ja ich kann ja gar nicht sinnvoll sagen
was die machen ist in ordnung da werden
leute skalpiert das eindeutig nicht in
ordnung also wurde ich in die diskussion
eintreten und nicht fragen was machen
die falsch die könnten mich prinzipiell
überzeugen
aber wenn du mir sagen es gehört zu
meiner ehre wenn ich sagen stopp was
dein ehre warum sollte denn er einen
status haben die es erlaubt jemanden zu
skalpieren
das würde ich nicht sehen aber könnte
sagen und genau aus den gründen die sie
einleitend gesagt habe wir sind neo
existenzialistische wesen wir sehen uns
und unseren sinn in der welt in einer
gewissen weise
nichts ist schlimmer als der sinn
verlust und wenn mein weltbild ein
weltbild essent diese ehre eine zentrale
rolle spielt dann lasse ich mich nicht
von anderen theatern selbst und hier
kommt jetzt das neo im neo
existenzialismus zum ich höre ja es gibt
tatsachen über uns ja das heißt die
moralischen das ist genau die rolle die
die moralischen tatsachen im neo
existenzialismus spielen die moralischen
tatsachen betreffen das was wir uns als
menschen einander schulden und die
moralischen tatsachen können wir auch
verfehlen wir können irrtümer begehen
und ich würde sagen ein kulturkreis
diese das genannt haben in dem menschen
einander skalpieren weil sie den
gedanken der ehre etwas zuschulden
scheinen verletzt den gedanken dass sie
sich einander etwas als menschen
schulden
das wäre das gespräch das also in diesem
fall mit diesen personen zu führen wäre
also sie würden sagen die crew als stamm
der 300 jahre lang existiert hat könnten
sich 300 jahre lang in einem falschen
verständnis dessen bewegt haben was gut
und richtig ist genau wenn das
nationalsozialistische terrorregime
tatsächlich 1000 jahre gedauert hätte
hätten die sich 1000 jahre getäuscht ja
also 1000 jahre hitler machen die
endlösung immer noch nicht moralisch
richtig da kann man sagen wir sind in
einer prima position wir sind am ende
eines fortschritts oder so stellen wir
uns das vor
das bringt ja auch moralische michael
crichton mit sich nämlich handlungen aus
der vergangenheit zu beurteilen man
überhebt sich ja leicht wenn man gerade
an den fortschritt geglaubt wie sie das
tun
deswegen postulieren ich auch in dem
buch das halte ich für einen wichtigen
teil unserer moralischen praktiken ein
prinzip der nachsicht das heißt manchmal
kommen moralische tatsachen ans licht
die uns vorher verstellt waren das
passiert in diesen monaten sehr häufig
und auch erfreulicherweise wir haben
sehr viele moralische fortschritte zu
über moralisierung oft wo man sagt vor
100 jahren war das ein rassist wobei die
beschreibung vielleicht gar nicht so
plausibel ist für die zeit genau
deswegen gilt hier ein prinzip danach
sicht aber das prinzip der nachsicht ist
auch eingeschränkt zur moral zur
moralischen urteil gehört ja auch dass
wir nicht einfach verurteilen weil wir
auch verlieben sind deswegen hab ich
gesagt ich würde mich in ein spaten
gespräch gegeben etwa mit menschen die
moralische praktiken pflegen die mir
vielleicht sogar abscheulich vor kein
offenes gespräch bei uns ist ein stein
liegen könnten ich könnte auch falsch
liegen ich bin mir ziemlich sicher
zunächst einmal dass ich nicht falsch
liege ich muss ja um in das gespräch ein
treten nicht gleich einzutreten ich
gleich meinen der andere hat recht
sondern die maxime wie das der philosoph
hans georg gadamer einmal in einem
spiegel gespräch gesagt hat sagt nur der
andere könnte recht haben ja das heißt
noch lange nicht so zu sagen dass ich
über laufen muss aber es heißt dass ich
das gespräch bis zu ende führen dass
dann wäre philosophie seine art kunst
unrecht zu haben wenn der andere bessere
argumente hat wenig froh dass er mir das
gezeigte unbedingt wie in allen anderen
wissenschaften ist das beste was einem
passieren kann ja dass man etwas gel
über seine eigenen fehler gelernt hat
wenn ich jetzt irgendwie lerne dass es
doch gar keine moralischen tatsachen
gibt und dass der gute alte nelis muss
richtig ist dann wäre das vielleicht
eine transformative erfahrung mein leben
würde sich ändern ja aber ich hatte eben
etwas gelernt glauben sie denn wirklich
dass sie jetzt noch in dem status in dem
sie jetzt sind als denker in ein
gespräch bieten können indem ihn
wirklich sagt der nihilismus ist richtig
sie haben als skeptiker begonnen sie
sind jetzt ein moralischer realist mir
scheint das gar nicht so überzeugen
sondern sie wissen wie es ist und sie
wollen es er verkünden
also natürlich behaupte ich zu wissen
wie es ist mein wissens anspruch kann
gelingen oder scheitern
ich kann gute gründe dafür anführen dass
ich glaube dass er gelingt ich bin mir
sicher dass mein wissens anspruch
gelingt aber diese sicherheit also meine
gewissheit im urteil
garantiert nicht die wahrheit meines
urteils gibt immer noch eine lücke
potenzielle zwischen meiner gewissheit
ja das richtige zu denken und der frage
ob ich das richtige denke das heißt
natürlich bin ich widerlegbar aber die
sache ist durchdacht also es ist nicht
so dass man irgendwie mit 23 zügen
sozusagen die schachpartie gewinnen kann
gegen das was ich aufgebaut habe auch
manchmal ein großmeister eröffnung habe
ich verstanden
das ist klar das ist auch wichtig das
ist bei das ist bei jedem spiel so ja
also wie gesagt das ist alles verliebe
ja aber das heißt natürlich nicht dass
ich das was ich glaube nicht glauben
noch zwei fragen zum abschluss wir
setzten ein mit der idee dass wir in
dunklen zeiten leben das gefiele viele
irrtümer haben die sehr verheerend
auswirken sich global andererseits an
gesagt wir sind weltweit in diesem
moralischen fortschritt gedient klickt
der widerspruch sind wir jetzt das
hellste oder das dunkelste zeit reiter
das können wir insgesamt natürlich nicht
beurteilen weil wir mittendrin stecken
auf der einen seite haben wir sehr viele
moralische fortschritte zu verzeichnen
wir sind viel sensibilisierter in den
letzten jahrzehnten führt zum beispiel
psychische gewalt geworden
erfreulicherweise in diesem zusammenhang
haben wir sehr viel gelernt zum beispiel
über geschlecht
geschlechtergerechtigkeit und zwischen
verschiedenen da gibt's wichtigen
fortschritt messbaren argumentierbar
selbstverständlich und es ist ja ein
nach heutigen maßstäben unvorstellbarer
gedanke das ist vor nicht allzu langer
zeit vor wenigen jahrzehnten etwa
unmöglich war für eine frau wenn sie
verheiratet war einfach irgendwie einen
beruf aufzunehmenden es unvorstellbar es
war schlichtweg ein fehler
das ist aber etwas was wir auch gelernt
haben das mussten alle lernen ja hätte
man den frauen zugehört hätte man das
auch schon früher wissen könnten
natürlich auf das dialogische wieder da
kommt das dialogische rein
die zweite frage die mich und treibt vor
allem als leser dieses buches fiktionen
sie strengen sich sehr sehr an zu sagen
es gibt das sinn fällt aller sennfelder
eine andere begriffe diese sind fällt
aller sinnvoll da ist ja gut man könnte
sagen gott ist die summe aller
sinnvollen felder die es gibt er ist
allwissend der weiß was da passiert und
er weiß auch was dort getan werden soll
weil er all gültig ist wenn ich ihre
bücher lese existiert gott nicht im
gegensatz zueinander
der krieg den gibt es gerade nicht wenn
gott das wäre so wie man ihn sich
vorstellt so wie sie gerade skizziert
haben dann gibt es gott nicht
allerdings glaube ich dass das also ich
gibt keinen allmächtigen allwissenden
all gütigen gott richtig das ist
prinzipiell unmöglich kann es nicht
geben können weil weisen ja dafür habe
ich argumentiert also wenn ob meine
beweise gelingen oder nicht ist immer
eine andere frage aber wenn meine
beweisführung gelingt dann kann es
diesen gott nicht geben
ich wurde allerdings auch sagen das
möchte ich hinzufügen dass der gott der
monotheistischen oder auch der
politischen sogenannten heiligen
dürften nicht er ist dort steht das
nicht dass ein philosophischer zusatz
erfindungen ja die von griechischen
philosophen insbesondere übernommen wo
also das heißt selbst unsere vorstellung
von gott müsste nach ihrer philosophie
modifiziert werden um sinnvoll zu sein
auf jeden fall gott wenn wir uns gott
vorstellen ja als jemand der außerhalb
der welt steht und sie irgendwie
geschaffen hat und so weiter
dann beginnt der lauter irrtümer ich
meine das ist die alte frage wie hat er
das denn gemacht gibt auch einen für sie
also ich meine man kann sagen es gibt
diesen interventionistischen gott der
vater da steht über allem der greift ein
gibt es eine andere vorstellung die sie
attraktiv finden ja ich würde sagen der
wirkliche gott ja der so genannten
heiligen schriften nehmen wir jetzt die
monotheistischen als paradigma weil dort
bei uns so üblich ist aber es gibt
natürlich auch den politisch muss aber
nehmen wir diesen gott ja von dem da
immer die rede ist von dem glaube ich
wird das so nicht gesagt auch nicht im
alten testament da ist nicht jemand der
außerhalb der welt steht und er bringt
irgendwie alles hervor und weiß alles
der ist ja involviert in die geschichte
der menschen gott ist gerade zu
verlieben
wenn man sich diese texte anschaut der
macht fehler und so weiter und außerdem
gibt es die freiheit der menschen in der
interaktion mit gott das heißt ich
glaube diese philosophische gedanken von
einem allwissenden gott ist eben ein
philosophischer gedanke den ich für
theologisch sogar unhaltbar halte ich
nehme mit auf gott sollten wir uns nicht
verlassen auf die philosophen vielleicht
vielleicht aber auf ihre philosophie
herzlichen dank dass sie heute da waren
rwe hat danke für das spannende gespräch
und nächste woche wird hier politisch zu
gast ist robert habeck der co
parteivorsitzende der grünen in
deutschland barbara bleisch spricht mit
dem promovierten
literaturwissenschaftler und extrem aus
über die moral hinter der politik und
fragt ob unser planet eigentlich noch zu
retten ist und wenn ja wie und jetzt
gleich schauen wir nach weißrussland und
begleiten den freien chor von minsk
dessen mitglieder täglich gegen das
repressive regime von alexander
lukaschenko an singen und dabei ihr
leben riskieren
bleiben sie also dran und existieren sie
weiter
[Musik]